[Music]
artificial intelligence is one of the
fastest growing fields today and recent
advancements in deep learning are
pushing the boundaries of what we can do
with AI deep learning is at the cutting
edge of self-driving cars music
generation and has even been used to
classify skin cancer with better
accuracy than human doctors we pioneered
a curriculum with industry experts like
Ian Goodfellow inventor of generative
adversarial networks and Sebastian Thrun
former head of the Google self-driving
car team once you complete this program
you oughta mentally admitted into our
robotics self-driving car and our other
artificial intelligence none of you
produce the feed of the eye is moving so
insanely fast it'll be fun to stay on
top together we'll implement models from
academic papers and connect with an
incredible online community of peers
throughout this program you'll complete
hands-on projects such as your first
neural network and generating realistic
images with a generative adversarial
Network and you'll get in-depth code
review from deep learning experts so
what are you waiting for start your
future today and join the deep learning
foundations nano degree program